let me tell you about what i think one
of the biggest problems is
sure i will always lay the blame at the
feet of the perpetrator if a woman is
wearing you know she's scantily clad
clothing and walks through an alley and
someone attacks her she was not asking
for it the perpetrator the criminal is
it
who should be punished who should be
blamed etc but there is personal
responsibility involved you need to be
aware of your own surroundings you need
to take some responsibility so i don't
think it's a one-for-one like when the
left says oh people should be allowed to
be drunkenly wandering around like i'm
not gonna go to an atm at three in the
morning all right so i'll blame the gun
control left and many of these democrats
in these big cities who who push for
these things
and now i'm gonna lay some blame at the
feet of conservatives who refuse to
fight back we had the story saint louis
gun waving couple plead guilty to
misdemeanor charges part of their plea
is that they will be giving up their
weapons they say mark and patricia
mccloskey who waved guns at protesters
last year who marched past their home
pled pleaded guilty thursday to
misdemeanors and agreed to give up their
weapons mark mccloskey will pay a 750
fighter for pleading guilty to fourth
degree assault a classy misdemeanor
patricia 62 must pay a two thousand
dollar fine after pleading guilty to
second second degree harassment a class
a misdemeanor mark mccloskey could have
faced 15 days in jail patricia could
have spent up to a year behind bars
neither will face jail time
do not vote for these people isn't the
guy running for officers
senate and he just tweeted don't worry i
have more guns to protect my family
where that came from do not
do not vote for this man he is a
spineless coward i wouldn't wait why is
he spineless when the cops came to take
his guns away he took a picture of him
from behind and said i don't want anyone
to think bad of these cops who are
confiscating oh i didn't know that oh oh
oh holy crap now he's dropping to his
knees
scared of the state coming for him
giving up his weapons but i have more i
don't care
dude get out of here should have fought
the legal battle you i cannot wait come
on you can't advise someone to be a
martyr would you i would not feel
comfortable taking on the state when
there's this whole public frothing at
the mouth mob and i'm being made to
political victim i'd do it
maybe you would but i don't think he's a
coward for being like i got a family
they've got me dead to rights because
they can write the law whatever they
want and it's going to cost me millions
of dollars and they're the the
government can tax me to pay for them i
i can't i think i think his comments are
interesting and i think i think they
provide us context here he said quote on
his twitter account i'm bringing this
from his account quote let me be clear i
am not surrendering any of my firearms i
will continue to be one of the strongest
advocates for the second amendment
and around the country the two weapons
that were seized from me were evidence
in a criminal case per the state of uh
mo they are to be incinerated so this is
what this what yeah
no i don't make any sense the state is
incinerating his weapons but he gets to
have something's evidence you return
into the person or you keep it sense
possibly but i guess this was a part of
their plea deal but why would they too
it's like it's like a circus it's like
they're doing this to entertain the
masses they're like look what we did
like this
when the cops came
they took a photo of the cops taking
their guns but from behind and said we
don't want to reveal the identities of
the officers because we don't want
people coming after him whatever and i
was like that's pathetic
the cops could have said no the cops
could have said we do not agree with
this and we will not enforce unjust laws
these these these black lives matter
individuals broke onto private property
and we even saw was it the ag of
missouri say that they may as well been
in their living room it was a private
lot it was it was a private property the
whole block was privately owned they
could have defended themselves now don't
get me wrong i think them coming out and
her like waving the gun was was very
dumb
i'm not a fan of that either but
they could have been very scared we
don't know what that's like she didn't
have good trigger uh discipline at all
as well and she was literally having her
finger on the trigger pointing the gun
out of her husband's head well and there
was also
there was also they said the firing pin
was reversed and the gun was inoperable
the uh there's two guns right there that
was the the ar-15 and what looked like a
revolver now no no it wasn't a revolver
um i don't know i don't remember what it
was but did it it was a small handgun
they claimed that the firing pin was
reversed and the gun was inoperable
when it was when it was brought into the
like the to the d.a for evidence they
dis they disassembled and reassembled it
and then said oh it works
so a lot of people are coming out and
saying the state altered the evidence to
claim it was a functioning device when
the mccloskey said they had used it in a
criminal trial before as evidence and so
the firing pin was reversed maybe
they're lying maybe they went inside and
immediately took it apart and did it i'm
not going to accuse them of that and i
don't think the state has evidence they
did that they just claimed that well
upon taking it apart putting it back
together we found it was functional
these people should have absolutely said
no they should have said i will see you
in court if no one will stand up to the
system the system will always win always
i i just i completely disagree with you
i think when you don't know someone's
personal circumstances it's really easy
to tell them fight but this is the state
i'm sorry i think at a certain point
some people like discretion is a better
form of valor and i would love me of all
people for f's sake would love it if
more people defied the state and stood
up to it but at a certain point you're
like okay look at duncan lemp uh what
happened with him like they shot he
killed him at three in the morning
through the window and they dragged his
pregnant girlfriend through the broken
glass and blighted her up yeah so you're
telling me that it's not that it's
impossible that the next time uh that
they're gonna make sure uh antifa goes
by his house and the cops are just gonna
take 9-1-1 put it on uh take the phone
off the hook and let nature take its
course
what do you mean meaning like
this kind of things happen all the time
when someone is an enemy to the state
they look the other way and make sure
that person gets taken care of yeah so i
mean when you're saying like you should
fight the state you ask them to really
take their life into their own hands now
i can understand how someone would do
that but it's also really easy to choose
to understand if someone would want to
know that do you know what would happen
if right now in chicago every single
person facing trial demand facing a
criminal an indictment or a criminal
charge asked for a jury trial they would
get
uh charged with higher charges not true
if in chicago every single person
awaiting a a arraignment or whatever
charge of the crime said jury trial they
would all instantly be dismissed
chicago you think they don't understand
that explain it because the city doesn't
have the capability to handle that many
trials at once so
wait wait wait okay here's the two i i
don't agree with you because what
happens is when places don't have
resources they're just going to keep you
in jail longer i know perhaps who have
been in jail for so long because of the
covid regulations and even covid has
stopped the court proceedings and what
they did is just keep people in jail
longer so i'll tell you this i got to
ask you you're saying that if everyone
who's arrested right now in chicago said
i demand a jury trial the chicago legal
systems you'll be like we can't do this
you're all going home
uh most of them probably would be
dismissed yes so when uh i ended up
getting charged with i think a class c
misdemeanor my brother got a class a
they threw a the worst of the easiest uh
actually i don't i don't know if a is
the worst i think he got it i think it
was a b okay i was facing 30 days my
brother was facing uh six months oh wow
and the uh it was like six months of
going to trial because long story short
some security guards at a mall falsely
accused us and when they realized that
they got the wrong guys in a shoplifting
uh they thought someone was shoplifting
they just lied to the cops the cops just
said whatever you say and arrested us
and charged us with like assault and
disorderly conduct
they said they will give us the maximum
penalty they said you will plead guilty
and you will take what we give you and
at first what happened was
my brother fearing six months said i'll
just plead guilty what what will you
have me doing said we're gonna give you
community service and then i said 30
days
i'll go to trial this will this will be
fun
when the prosecutor heard that i said i
wanted to go to trial over a slap on the
wrist they would give me community
service she audibly screamed in the
courtroom
shocked what
and then the judge had to tell her to
chill out our lawyer walks back over to
us and he and my brother is like why is
she yelling what happened
well when when she found out that you he
like to me being charged with like a
slap on the wrist level crime wanted a
jury trial do you understand how much
work that is for them so she's she's
kind of mad yeah my brother goes
effort i'm going to i want a trial now
too and he goes you're sure he was yup
jerry trial he goes okay he walks back
over and we see him go up to the to the
prosecution of the judge and we hear her
scream again and the judge starts saying
calm down
and then they talk for a little bit the
our lawyer walks back over to us and
says the judge wants to see you in his
chambers and the judge said
what is going on
and we said america that's what happened
and he goes here's what's going to
happen i don't want to hear any lawsuits
i want this all to go away the charges
are being dismissed you're free to go is
that it and we were like yes your honey
goes have a nice day we asked the lawyer
what happened
and the judge when he found out that my
brother changed his mind and wanted a
jury trial on a slap on the wrist charge
courts it was it was a court would get
court supervision and and community
service nothing right
when the judge heard that and he said to
the lawyer
why are your clients now trying to get a
trial out of this it's five o'clock we
want to go home and he went um your
honor
because they're innocent yeah and he
went oh
huh oh case dismissed in my chambers and
then he got up and walked in the problem
is too many people just say well because
they're advising community defender we
were told to by our lawyer he said guys
this is what's going to happen you're
going to get community service it's all
going to be over you're going to go home
and play video games and you don't even
got to do anything get one of your your
dad's a firefighter ask him to sign the
papers you're done here's something and
i said no
i want a jury to hear what happened when
they accused me of shoplifting beat the
crap out of me and my brother we did
nothing wrong and i'm gonna stand up
there with conviction and say i refuse
to be beaten down by lying security
guards who use the state because they
screwed up and we won because of it too
many people are just scared i would
gladly i know it was just 30 days they
could have been facing a felony but i
would gladly have families
and she actually pointed a gun at people
and and she'll never like isn't that
brandishing that's just me dude but i'm
talking i'm hot-headed they're going to
make sure that jury is going to be
filled with people who saw her
brandishing that weapon let me just make
i'll go ahead well i'm very happy you
brought up duncan lamp but in missouri
the attorney general was one of the
attorney general's influence and
sponsored by george soros she had a
proverbial hard-on for these people uh
the police officers at first said we're
not going to listen to the d.a
yeah yeah the the d.a in missouri uh was
specifically going after them police
officers at first said that they
wouldn't comply
but then officially they they complied
later on uh through a little bit of
protest so that's important context here
as well sorry go ahead and can i give
people some some legal background yeah
speaking hypothetically because i'm not
a lawyer and i'm positioned to discuss
this in a legal context but
hypothetically it's a fairy tale if you
happen to be on a grand jury here's how
grand juries work right it's going to be
like 25 people they're going to bring
you the d.a is going to bring you some
evidence and that evidence is not there
to get a conviction all that evidence
has to do is to say in the eyes of the
grand jury there is enough evidence here
to pursue charges meaning it's not
nothing it's something and and the the
joke is that any good d.a can get you to
indict a ham sandwich this is basically
a formality maybe the founding fathers
era whatever
that said most people hypothetically are
tend to be in in want of a leader like
they're in that room they don't know
what's going on they want to do the
right thing they don't know what that is
the only guidance they're getting is
from that uh junior d.a so they're going
to come in and there's going to cop
hypothetically and say oh we found this
leafy substance in this guy's house and
now this 18 year old kid is going to be
thrown in jail possibly with rapists and
murderers his entire life is ambiguous
until he gets charged or not if you are
in that grand jury
and you say hey guys
there's nothing holding us to return
what they call a true bill which means
he's indicted we can just vote no and
ignore the evidence and and someone
could say listen you we're here we have
a responsibility
do you really want to ruin this kid's
life because he had a lot of wheat in
his house and was probably selling it
just think about everyone you know who's
ever done weed do you think they should
go to jail think about what jail means
it's not like i can't go to my job it's
like i'm locked in a little room with
people that i know
kill children
rape women repeatedly and what will
happen hypothetically speaking is that
those jurors now they've been given
permission to do the right thing be like
why am i ruining this kid's life this i
know people smoke weed i don't think
they should go to jail maybe they
shouldn't be doing my thing and that d.a
will come back and say how did you guys
say and they'll say
all charts been dropped and they will
not be able to ask you why and they're
just going to be very very confused
because this hasn't happened but you
will have been a position to save some
kid's life and he will never know who
did it or why but he'll be very grateful
and you can go to sleep that you made
the world a better place there's also
jury nullification that is jury
notification well yeah so but you could
be on an actual criminal proceeding
right so in the grand jury yes if you
are actually sitting on a jury and they
say this guy uh you know had weed or
something and you don't think they
should be in prison for it you can say
not guilty right and they're like but
the evidence it's like the cops found it
they presented it he admitted it was his
yeah not guilty
strongly i strongly recommend people
look into jury nullification and
whenever you get a jury notice don't see
it as something negative see it as an
opportunity to provide services to the
community that could actually help
people and i just want to make a quick
correction the missouri attorney general
actually filed to dismiss the charges
but it was prosecutor kim gardner that
was the one that was strongly going
thank you for the clarification and and
i will also add the governor said that
he wanted to pardon the gun-toting
couple so what happened to a trial and
that would harden them he announced that
he would pardon and they should have
dropped charges every step of the way
and you know what this is the look i i
hear what you're saying but if the
leaders we have are the ones willing to
to to drop the knee to the enemy
combatants these aren't leaders these
are just two old people
sure no they're not vendors then there's
there's there's no cohesive uh
resistance there is cohesive cohesive
resistance doesn't have to be unanimous
i i think i tim i just think it's really
really easy for us to sit here and tell
people we've never met what do people
tell you what you should be doing all
the time i'm sure you don't like it
i mean in what context like online
they're like oh your show should be like
this your show should be like that so on
and so forth it's like
you don't know me like keep thank you
for your opinion so we don't know this
couple we don't know maybe she's got
some kind of illness i don't know
yeah perhaps i'm just like i said maybe
a little bit more hot-headed like like i
mentioned it could be my soviet blood so
my soviet dna is like once the state has
gotten you in the eye of sauron do
whatever you can to get out of the eye
of sorrow get out fully you know
my family fled communism in in poland
because it was just getting too crazy
right right that i understand that i
understand that the issue i take here is
that you i think i i i started
interrupting you but it sounds like
you're saying the system works and just
because it worked for you guys i don't
know that it's at all a guarantee that's
going to work for these two so when
you're a 63 year old woman to go to jail
the system didn't work for us but you
got off it was it was clear the only
reason we did was because the system
didn't want to deal with two jury trials
sure but the point is that's how broken
it was
the point is you you managed to get the
result that you wanted here's here's the
the issue i take with this for the most
part certainly i understand there are
circumstances where you you are a
strategic retreat makes sense yeah it
would be dumb if you're like i'm by
myself and there's 500 people in front
of me but i'm charging it anyway that's
that's really dumb they had the support
of the right they had the support of the
governor they the support of the state
ag i didn't think they could have won
this they could have been convicted and
then he the governor could have made a
statement saying i refuse to allow this
in my state unconditional pardon
he could have done it for whatever
reason they had no faith
so they decided just to to get out with
what they could
give their weapons up the entire
you know i would not put my freedom in
the hands of a governor
no matter what he said publicly at any
time because that word is worth nothing
to me and he would throw me on the bus
in two seconds it would help his
re-election yeah probably and i think
therein lies a big part of the problem
and the frustration i have is that
the left absolutely will do everything
in their power to win kamala harris will
publicly solicit donations to get
criminals and rioters out of prison and
the right can't even rely on their own
to to support them correct yeah
it's frustrating i wanted to point out i
think maybe there is a time and a place
to bend the knee when the villain's like
on your knee and then you go down on
your knee and he walks up to you and
you're like yeah you do like a giant
uppercut
one of the things i'm talking about
perhaps in my next book the white pill
which is a lot about the soviet union is
i don't think people in this country i
know people in this country and i have
no doubt luke and you and you you all
back me up are completely oblivious
to what the state can do to people to
get them to bend the knee it's not like
good cop why are you why are you making
this we said we're oblivious to it i
think a lot of americans are oblivious
to it oh you're saying not us not us
not the people in this room but i'm
saying a lot of americans like
like i had a when castro died right
there's all these laudatory um
obituaries about him and i'm like you
know in a way it's kind of good that you
guys have no idea what this is like that
you think like oh he's basically like a
liberal democrat or like a trump figure
like you have no clue and i want a world
in a sense where people like i kind of
get that hypothetically but i can't
imagine this being reality so i can
appreciate that so the things that the
soviets did to break these people they
haven't come over here yet but one of
the things they always do like they'll
arrest people on a friday night and they
want them to squeal they're in jail till
monday and it's like i'll need to break
one of you and the offer is good for
that one person so who's it going to be
monday morning they're they're banging
that door and you can't blame them yeah
my favorite is seeing people wear czech
guevara shirts
and understanding that history and
context and uh
you're absolutely right i had family
members that were tortured by the
government of course uh
under a communist regime and when you
wake up to that reality when you speak
to your family when you hear the stories
when when you know so much knowledge is
passed on to you which which barely
happens the united states had it too
good for too long and i think now we're
finally dealing with a lot of the larger
ramifications of what happens when when
things are too good you know the cia
didn't know how to torture people at
gitmo so they had to use kgb manuals
they didn't we didn't have any
background yes
interesting look this up double check
that maybe i'm talking on my butt but
just double check me but i'm 99 sure
that's okay i suppose the issue i have
right now is that there's uh i got to
say one more thing tim don't you think
it's not maybe it's not literal torture
it's it's not literal torture but if
you're like a senior citizen close to it
and you're in prison over a weekend
that's gonna really do a huge number on
you psychologically come on i mean i was
in jail for a few days for for doing
journalism and reporting and it takes a
toll on you you definitely don't want to
be in there and then you to know your
wife is somewhere in this building
separated from you and you like i hope
she's okay and you know how she is and
she doesn't even know how to hold a gun
correctly that's tim that's scary and
trauma makes people make you know very
conflict diverse decisions
i guess uh
i think the larger lesson here i'm
hot-headed yeah i think the larger can
explain it i've been i've been in
conflict situations where my life was at
risk and i've returned to those
situations
and perhaps it's because i don't have
children maybe sure uh when i was in
brazil i went to the was it called
shiodado uh policia the city of police
the police city it's like their big
compound and we had plain clothes cops
basically walk up to us
take us in take our phones shut them off
they brought us into this back area into
this closed no window with the couch and
i said the first thing i did as soon as
they started taking us before they took
our phones i texted i was one of those
advice like we're being taken by
brazilian secret police or something
undercovers and i don't know where
they're bringing us but just so you know
here we are yeah then they took our
phones shut them off they brought us in
this back room and i started laughing i
was like so this is where we get beaten
up and tortured
and they held us there
started interrogating us and then after
about like a half an hour someone ran in
you know panicked in portuguese and they
brought us back out and apologized
so
you know experiencing that and then
not the end of the world but certainly
being brought through this complex and
then being brought in this into this
back room not knowing what to expect or
where they're bringing us and also uh i
i've also written vehicles with
i don't know how to describe individuals
violent extremists and revolutionaries
armed with guns i was i was in
charlottesville i i mean i i know you're
talking about this this stuff gets scary
really quick but i i returned to those
places uh not the same specific ones
that that have actually spoken out
against but like experiencing venezuela
where i was accused of being a spy and
forced to flee the country and then
having the venezuelan uh someone hack my
friends facebook to send me fake
messages to get me to make phone calls
then to just go back into thailand you
know i understand like i'm not gonna
return to venezuela i can't sure i can't
go to thailand but i would go initially
constantly facing that danger i'm well
aware of what it means to stand up and
fight and i'm well aware that uh
you must plant
the trees whose shade you know you'll
never sit beneath if you want a society
to grow great that means for me
personally strategy is involved right so
when it comes to censorship on youtube
one of the biggest criticisms we get is
tim why won't you just say it well i'm
not going to get the whole show banned
right and and and our opportunity to
speak the truth by saying one thing but
that's why we're building a website we
have to be strategic about it so i will
i will contend i don't know everything
about the mccloskey situation and
perhaps a strategic retreat made sense
i'll give one a scenario where it would
make perfect sense to everybody which is
what if they have a kid who's like mom i
really don't need you to be the face of
the gun rights movement can we just make
this go away and i want to have a normal
family i don't want to be famous that is
a perfectly good reason to be like yeah
what you know what i'm not going to
fight this i disagree but the father's
running to be a senator sure that's who
knows but i'm saying like that would be
one scenario maybe it's not literally
them where i could be like you know what
i'm not going to do this yeah
i don't know wife is like i don't have a
fortune i i've uh uh
and she could have individually sure
taken a deal um i i just grew up
constantly frustrated at the lack
unity solidarity how's that for a word
when i would see my friends constantly
complain about how they work for a
restaurant and it's unfair they're not
getting paid enough and i'd say so if
you all agree why don't you all just
stop working and they're like oh no i
have to and i'm like there's five of you
you could literally just walk out the
front door and stand there and say we're
not going to walk back in the building
unless we get another dollar an hour and
they'd say yes please get back to work
well i can't do that i'm like well then
you're not going to get your dollar an
hour like what do you mean if people
just stood up for themselves if everyone
finally just agreed we'd be done with it
if people had principal value strength
courage and were willing to make the
sacrifices to defend freedom individual
liberties we would have never have
headed at risk in the first place it's
coordination too you need all all these
values along with uh like some sort of
sociological coordination because if you
do it one by one you just just whack
them all it's true yeah it's true and
that's the thing if everyone in chicago
demanded a jury trial what i bet would
happen and i think if you thought about
this story you would think of this
happen too they would take a very few
case up front make real examples out of
them uh charge them with everything that
they could and then ask everyone else
you sure you want the jury trial and if
they said yep i i i think a lot of those
people would break and i wouldn't blame
him for one bit that the point is for
everyone to stand up and say i demand a
jury trial would be them
standing strong
assuming the people don't break they win
but but i i don't see any scenario where
an entire population acts in concert as
as pressure increases it's just i i i
agree i agree the problem is the they
don't work together sure if this the
system cannot maintain that many jury
trials
barely a fraction of them but that's why
you have public education so that these
kids are taught
from kindergarten before they can really
walk and read that the authorities are
genuinely good people who maybe they get
it wrong sometimes maybe not always
smart they're a little ignorant
sometimes but they do want what's best
for everyone that you have to punish
some people to save everybody else
they're the good guys so it's very hard
to realize as an adult when this has
been your entire context that you are
means to an end for these people in law
enforcement that they have certain
numbers and quotas they want to meet
that they get off on getting those
convictions or else this wouldn't be
their job because how could you sleep at
night if you're putting away people you
even suspect are innocent so yeah like
it's it's a it's much more malevolent
and what they were doing to you and your
brother was you and your lawyer who you
had was another version of good cop bad
cop because then you have the lady
screaming and your lawyer could be like
hey i'm a good guy i'm just going to get
your community service how can you lose
look at this crazy lunatic you don't
want to deal with bad cop i'm good gop
i'm your buddy and you're most people be
like hey i want to listen to good cop
i'm going to take this deal
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
tim
channel
irl monday through friday at 8pm where
you can leave comments and super chat
and we actually will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you